hey guys so I'm just taking a break here
with some coffee after I filmed a very
long video check it out
the video is about Jordan Peterson my
thoughts on Jordan Peterson and I
thought okay I'll take a break and I'll
just uh let you guys know what's gonna
come out soon so keep your eyes out and
then I want to introduce you to someone
some of you've probably seen look at
this guy when I'm done filming he just
want to sit on my lap
there we go hello
Togo hello
ah you lost interest all right this is
Togo
very very small dog and then we have
little chibi over there cheeb
so I just wanted to show you guys
um My Little fur kids and the kids fur
kids Nikita is also there maybe I can
show her can I know no obviously says no
no she's got a pajamas on so maybe next
time anyway I'll catch you guys in the
next video love you guys thank you for
all the support we'll see you soon
cheers